[Music]
welcome to the drama behind the scene
show I'm your host definition and it
looks like it's not just regular people
who are still disappointed with the way
that the finale of Game of Thrones went
down at July's San Diego comic-con Seth
Rogen who was part of a panel to discuss
his work on preacher and where the show
was heading in the upcoming season
recently ripped into right as DN D and
yeah a just completely tore them apart
the preacher panel was due to take place
after the game of Thrones one in which
writers D and D were going to answer
questions alongside the cast and talk
about the process behind the show
however they both cancelled last minute
probably because of the backlash that
circulated around it this year and this
left a lot of people involved with the
organisation of the event in a bad
situation as they had to scramble
together scheduled to try and work
something out
needless to say this angered a lot of
fans most notably Seth Rogen who had the
following to say about the two and the
show's ending following the game of
Thrones panel which is a [ __ ]
nightmare just objectively I also know
that there are owners didn't show up
because they didn't want to answer
questions about the show
I have bought one of the creators of
Game of Thrones but I am the creator of
other TV show so feel free to ask me any
Game of Thrones questions you guys head
throughout the night I'm not an expert I
didn't read the books but I watched the
show so I can give you my insights and
thoughts just as to see what series
finale is gonna be more satisfying
preacher Game of Thrones I think
hopefully I won't be I'm here at least
so I think that's also like to say if I
would imagine those guys regret making
brand the King because ultimately he
doesn't have the best story and that's
[Laughter]
give you buy take I don't know for sure
I've met them a couple times there guys
why did Aria wear a face again yeah yes
you learned all that face [ __ ] where'd
it go what you do with those faces it is
sad that it's over it's weird that it's
over is it going on do you think that
they made a mistake by not having Jaime
Lannister killer see you don't want to
follow these people over three years
even over six years in front they
trapped in the rubble Khan anticlimactic
anyway are we gonna get to see Jesse
Custer fly in on a dragon
I wasn't gonna make a joke about how you
look like Woody Harrelson but now I'm
going because you made that - alright
don't do one of those things cuz it's
because it ends it's over you mean if we
put us in a weird position if you guys
now made like a petition to save
creature because it's over and we don't
and we would have to do some other thing
which would be super it would be hard
for us you will reshoot the last season
right we're gonna crowd source the
reshooting of the final episode man I
just found this hilarious to be honest
like the petition thing absolutely
killed me in him talking about we
shooting the final season which is of
course massive news stories from a
couple of months ago when the show was
out and I'm just really glad that more
people with platforms are kind of coming
forward and voicing how bad they thought
it was instead of just the fans as this
kind of gave some of the cast the hump
and they slammed a lot of people who had
supported the show for the best part of
a decade and called them toxic even
though a lot of them were offering up
legitimate criticism honestly it's good
that someone in a position like Rogen is
calling out D&D because this was getting
hyped up as the panel where everything
was supposed to be finally cleared up
but the fact that they know showed it
really just cements that they don't have
respect for anyone's opinion if it's
negative they were kind of showered with
praise for 10 years and then as soon as
people lobbied a bit of negativity
towards them it made them run for the
hills I actually think it's a worse look
for them they didn't show up as had they
went to comic-con and stood behind the
final season that most people probably
would have respected it but now it's
just another big controversy that
surrounds the entire season obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
clip and if you think Rogan was in the
wrong for addressing it or if you stand
by what he said comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out my breakdown of the huge
San Diego comic-con Marvel panel which
would be linked at the end I go over all
of the announcements so it
definitely worth checking out if you
want something to watch after this if
you want to come talk to me about movies
TV shows games and comic books and you
can follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see over there after this
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]